[Musique]
voici les premières images de l'arsenal
trouvée par les policiers dans la
voiture du forcené de béziers malgré les
barrages son complice court toujours
question les armes de guerre ont-elles
fait leur apparition dans les cités des
éléments de réponse dans un instant
première journée test pour les couloirs
de bus fermés à paris on craignait la
pagaille apparemment les bouchons sont
restées limitées trois questions ce soir
à bertrand delanoë le maire de paris
bonsoir monsieur le maire il ya tout à
l'heure la sphère des anticholestérols
témoignages inédits sur les méthodes de
bailleurs le laboratoire allemand a
multiplié cadeaux et pression sur les
médecins pour les inciter à prescrire le
médicament aujourd'hui retirée on
l'appelait le petit prince patrice
martin enfant prodige du ski nautique
qui a tout gagné pendant plus de 20 ans
arrête la compétition informations
france 2 elle est confirmée par
l'intéressé nous l'entendons bonsoir à
tous et merci de votre attention
direction béziers pour commencer presque
deux jours après la fusillade qui a fait
un mort
ce sont des actes de guerre comme en
palestine ou en ex yougoslavie voilà ce
que déclare ce soir le maire de la ville
raymond couderc les policiers
recherchent le complice et s'interroge
sur le mobile de ce coup de folie sur
place léo lamberton
[Musique]
bonjour à tous ce flash spécial pour
vous annoncer c'est très spectaculaire
explosion se serait un attentat selon
les médias américains à new york au
coeur de manhattan
en vous découvrez l'image en l'espace de
20 minutes deux avions ont percuté les
prestigieux tours jumelles du world
trade center donc dans le quartier de
wall street en plein jour à 20h45 heure
américaine
les tours sont en feu vous l'avez vu pas
de bilan pour l'instant on parle de
plusieurs morts au moins et de dizaines
de blessés puisque à ce moment de la
journée
ces bureaux du quartier de wall street
sont déjà bien sûr occupée bonsoir à
tous
il est 14 heures à new york édition
spéciale soirée spéciale états unis
presque une semaine après les attentats
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci de votre attention
huit jours après c'est une certitude le
raz de marée en asie du sud est bien la
plus grande catastrophe naturelle de
l'histoire récente édition spéciale ce
soir france télévisions avec la
fondation de france mobilise toutes ses
équipes pour entretenir les landes
soutien au pays éprouvés et vous
informer du mieux possible
un élan massif et c'est notre premier
titre dans les écoles dans les
entreprises dans les prisons les bonnes
volontés font boule de neige
35 millions d'euros ont été recueillis
par les associations c'est du jamais vu
en si peu de temps
nous l'évoquerons avec nos invités
l'abbé pierre et bernard kouchner image
symbole aussi aux états unis où george
bush a chargé son verre et son
prédécesseur bill clinton de récolter
des fonds
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous
un titre principal dans l'actualité ce
soir les terribles conséquences de la
tempête dans l'ouest de la france on
compte maintenant 59 morts et disparus
la plupart noyées dans leurs maisons en
vendée en charente maritime
les pompiers continuent à chercher les
rescapés les dégâts sont énormes et
milliers d'habitations sont encore sous
les eaux on sait maintenant que
plusieurs digues ont été submergés le
long des côtes
nicolas sarkozy s'est rendu sur les
lieux il a promis une aide immédiate de
3 millions d'euros
et on s'interroge déjà sur les règles
d'urbanisation images reportages
témoignages
nos équipes sont sur place nous serons
en direct avec nos envoyés spéciaux et
nos invités et nous essaierons de
comprendre ce qui s'est passé exactement
bienvenue donc dans cette édition
spéciale il y a un jour et demi la
tempête balayé la france et ce n'est
qu'aujourd'hui qu'on en mesure
pleinement l'impact premières images
regarder elles ont été tournées cet
après midi à bord d'un hélicoptère et en
réalise à quel point l'océan est entré
dans les terres les rues les routes les
jardins les résidences sont encore noyé
et dans plusieurs zones du littoral le
niveau de l'eau ne diminue pas en raison
d'une nouvelle grande marée le pompage
commence à peine on reste encore dans
une situation d'urgence des plans
aériens que nous a envoyé tout à l'heure
alain darrigrand devons-nous redouter le
nucléaire vous avez sans doute votre
opinion la question n'est pas nouvelle
mais elle ressurgit brusquement avec
cette tragédie japonaise que nous
apprend-elle sur les fragilités de la
filière c'est l'un des enjeux de
l'édition exceptionnel de ce soir
le journal de 20h david pujadas
bonjour à tous au sommaire de ce journal
spécial le japon demande l'aide des
experts internationaux face à la menace
nucléaire une deuxième explosion s'est
produite dans la centrale de fukushima
et le système de refroidissement d'un
troisième réacteur est en panne
l'accident pourrait passer du niveau 4
au niveau 5 ou 6 images
reportage et une invitée anne lauvergeon
présidente d'areva bonsoir et à tout à
l'heure
dans la foulée plusieurs pays européens
ont décidé de geler leurs programmes
nucléaires
quelle sécurité quels risques on y
reviendra à la fin de ce journal avec
notamment un débat entre claude allègre
et daniel cohn bendit
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous la france frappé la
france blessé douze morts quatre blessés
dans un état grave la tacc contre
charlie hebdo et l'attentât le plus
meurtrier depuis plus de 50 ans parmi
les victimes quatre dessinateur cabu
wolinski charb tignes où ce l'économiste
bernard maris ces deux policiers des
terroristes lourdement armés qui sont
toujours en fuite
des centaines d'hommes sont à leurs
trousses la piste islamiste est
privilégiée ce soir de grands
rassemblements sont en cours dans les
grandes villes
le plan vigipirate est au maximum en
ile-de-france les grands magasins les
lieux de culte et les transports publics
sont placés sous protection renforcée
édition spéciale sur cette journée noire
pour la presse et pour la france avec
nos envoyés spéciaux avec nos invités
nombreux pour évoquer cette épreuve et
cette nouvelle donne aussi pour le pays
j'ajoute que dans quelques minutes le
président de la république s'adressera
aux français à l'elysée où les drapeaux
sont en berne
[Musique]
bonjour à tous le jour se lève
la france a été frappé de façon inédite
par le terrorisme inédite par l'ampleur
puisque on parle déjà d'un bilan d'au
moins 120 morts inédite par le mode
opératoire puisque plusieurs attaques
terroristes six ou sept au total la
plupart à paris l'autre où les autres au
stade de france autour du stade de
france sont donc produite hier soir il
ya à peine neuf heures donc
le journal de 20h david pujadas
bonsoir à tous dans l'actualité
ce soir nous évoquerons d'abord notre
enquête sur le manger au restaurant
voilà on reste dans l'économie et le
social avec donc vous le constater cette
intrusion sur le plateau de plusieurs
intermittents du spectacle nous avons
donc décidé de leur laisser la parole
une minute pour exprimer leurs
revendications
messieurs dames je vous laisse la place
à les y prenez nos sièges et nous vous
écoutons ou plutôt adressez-vous ici au
micro et nous vous écoutons un merci
voilà petit souci vous vous en rendez
compte avec cette occupation du plateau
nous rendons l'on tait nous ne pouvons
pas faire ce journal bien sûr non je
suis très calme jeudi juste tu m'informe
que tu bien non le décor du journal ça
vous plaît je puisse vous dire que
franchement vous m'avez bluffé pendant
les deux mineurs vous avez raconté des
choses très dures mais toujours avec la
bauxite et c'est à dire le costume
parallèle à la table la coupe qui a été
fait par la kintoz changer real ce
poujadisme
c'était dur après après rachid arhab je
me disais qu'est qui ils vont nous
mettre charge à vous dire si c'est pour
ça que je vous allez est-ce que vous
avez une extra mémoire question
accablante habituellement c'est bien ce
que jésus en fin d'études à vie mais qui
veut faire le contact quand même avec
pujadas vous êtes espagnol aussi dans la
vidéo ci dessus et comme les femmes du
6e étage deuxième étage un million et
demi c'est un miracle alors évidemment
quand vous faites une représentation
deux heures où vous avez essayé le plus
possible de ne pas trahir l'altitude la
puissance la beauté du langage et quels
cas vous dis oh [ __ ] quelle mémoire tu
as l'impression que c'est parfait le
plus important parce qu'on peut imaginer
des acteurs avec beaucoup de mémoire qui
soit très rasoir mais je vous assure
qu'on se pose la question
vous comprenez français david j'ai dit
que je répondrai à aucune question a
commencé mon 21 c'est pas vrai c'est pas
ton 20 heures si c'était votre 20 ans
parce que c'est mon affaire
alors qu'est ce que j'avais fait avant
je prenais un café un café
poids de l'élu a quarter parce qu'on est
restés là-bas djamel attendait mais je
vous amène cup
j'ai prévu moi je savais que vous alliez
insisté avec vos questions prenez un
café
aucun présentateur du jt d'après un café
internet et profitez-en c'est sympa en
fait vous avez envie que je prenne un
peu de repos exactement
et j'ai un café pour vous aussi
exactement j'ai tout prévu david ne vous
inquiétez pas on comprend un café tous
les deux commencé revêt la famille david
ça va pas mal mais c'est à vous que j'ai
envie de vous plus que de poser la
question mais je vous ai dit que je ne
rendrai pas ça le problème
d'accord alors qu'est ce que vous avez
envie de dire ben je sais pas du tout
vous comment vous allez est ce que à
force de présenter des mauvaises
nouvelles toujours des mauvaises
nouvelles vous rentrez pas chez vous un
peu et un fonctionnaire des ca des ports
gares dès ce soir il y avait la victoire
des handballeurs français et l'a fait
sur les champs elysées bon vous regarder
le jt vous trouvez qui a trop de
mauvaises nouvelles chez mon sentiment
c'est vrai et ça me fait mal au coeur
pour vous
[Musique]